tailored sweatpants they're attacking
the legs of men across America the
question is look guys we're gonna just
try to be really frank with you here you
got to do this [ __ ]
tailored sweatpants it's a thing right
fall 2014 where we just saw go wow
michael lockrey
what do you think about taylor swift
answer you into it it's actually pretty
dope down Burnham right now cool as this
train to sort of taken off you see some
guys doing it right and some guys doing
it wrong so I want to get your advice
what is the difference between slam and
just like to type not oversized so that
you look like you're wearing a pair of
dad sweatpants right also you don't want
them to be so tight that they look like
tights right every once awhile you'll
see that like the other thing I'm seeing
is guys who are trying to wear them
outside of like you know going to the
bodega and they're kind of ready if
you're buying them from us there that's
not the case they're gonna hole up yeah
the holdup what's the key to avoiding
like weirdness in your zone that's what
they're you definitely want to avoid
weirdness in your zone what's that can
be a big time problem almost have a
little bit of like a drop down slouchy
top block if you're a super tight
through the calf and ankle yep not so
much on that top pack so guys everyone
loves shopping online I love shopping
online but if you're buying a new brand
of tailored sweatpants please try them
on first what kind of underwear
personally I always go boxer briefs
preferably like microfiber so you can
breathe right horrible like spend a
little bit extra money that your setup
guy are these man the stack can you can
you explain that and Michael maybe you
can help us illustrate thank you sir we
engineer all of our French terry to be
super thick it's comfortable of course
but it has the ability to stack just
like denim sag them a little bit maybe
pull them up on your ankle wallet so
they sort of bunch up and if you find
them with the right material and they'll
stay like that right now there's nothing
worse than like having some
kind of engineer that all day long so
that's why you know it's good to buy
something that kind of holds its formal
is it something sturdy yes I'm a sturdy
alright guys that's it thanks for
watching if you got any style questions
for GQ leave them in the comments and
we'll see you next